I want to be happy about the so called
basic income experiment that is being
done in Finland but it is really set up
to fail and I'll tell you why in a
second we've been talking about basic
income for a long time and there are
many many movements which as part of the
world view that they espouse really
point to basic income as something we
should be seriously considering there's
this the the post scarcity theorists who
say we are really heading towards a
world where basic goods including food
even services like shelter and health
care have no real need to be scarce and
therefore don't even really need to be
in the for-profit world and we should
really put a basic income as part of our
worldview so that we can disconnect some
of these activities from needing to have
a quote formal job there are those who
have been following the job automation
movement and the reality that technology
is now destroying more jobs than it
creates if you realize that as a planet
we are going in the direction of fewer
industries even having available jobs a
basic income fits there as well the
other scenarios there are also some
other scenarios we've talked about that
point to a basic income great so Finland
is going to sort of move forward with a
basic income trial the Ministry of
Social Affairs and Health has put
together a bill proposing a basic income
experiment to test the effects of these
guaranteed non-conditional cash payments
for individuals in the country huge
fantastic right not really they are
going to select several thousand
individuals who were already receiving
unemployment benefits and they're going
to say okay instead of unemployment
benefits where you are expected to be
looking for a job and these are of
limited time and they're also
conditional based on fulfilling certain
requirements job training job hunting
etc we're gonna change it and instead
you're going to get five hundred and
sixty euro per month and you don't have
to do anything this is unconditional
money where you can just get this money
you don't have to be looking for a job
etc and then they're going to see how
men
of those people ultimately get jobs
compared to the people who are on the
conditional unemployment what on earth
are you going to prove by this if you're
really wanting to do a serious test of
basic income you need to take a sample
that includes for example if you have 5%
unemployed in the country you have
another 5% who are underemployed and
then you have 15% who are retired for
example and 75% who are in the workforce
full-time you need to give the basic
income to a representative sample 75% of
your sample needs to be working
full-time 5% of your sample needs to be
working part-time but wanting to work
full time etc you're not going to prove
anything by taking people who are
already on unemployment benefits and
saying now you're going to be put on
unconditional cash payments and you have
no requirement whatsoever to get a job
this seems to me like an experiment
Jason that is set up to fail because
what's going to happen more than likely
is you're dealing only with a group who
already doesn't have a job and you're
going only to that group and saying now
you don't even need to look for one I
don't know how this could possibly be a
success the only thing I can relate to
choose I know I was hearing an article
about the flood in Louisiana and how
these people are without job without
home etc and part of the unemployment
process is they have to go to I think
one or two days a week they have to go
to unemployment like how to become
employed meetings so I'm not sure if
this is part of the catch-22 or they
don't have to go through this kind of
pseudo looking for job process they can
actually look for jobs the only thing I
can maybe think of them maybe the only
silver lining here but it's amazingly
optimistic yeah I understand what you're
saying which is if some of the
mechanisms that are required to stay on
unemployment actually take up time and
prevent you from really looking for jobs
freeing people from that might actually
get them to go and and spend more time
looking for jobs the the paradigm of
this test is completely wrong especially
when we're considering that much of the
basic income theories aren't predicated
on the idea that we would use income in
order to get more people working in the
traditional types of jobs that we
to exist now the point is to look at
basic income as an element of the
significant changes that are no doubt
going to happen to society over the next
50 years I think this is a bogus way to
test this I guess it's good to be doing
something I think it's set up to fail
and if you disagree I definitely want to
hear from you because I don't get how
we're going to get anything positive
from this test that Finland is doing